If you know how to create your own analysis, then you're
ready to choose a dataset. Now, we don't want you to use
a dataset that comes with our, or in our package, such as
the diamonds dataset or the empty cars dataset. Instead, you can choose
one of four datasets that we've collected or you can choose
to find your own. Now, I want to caution you, finding your
own dataset can take a lot of time. We only recommend finding
and cleaning your own dataset if you're comfortable with data munching or
if you're ready for a serious challenge. In
the instructor notes you'll find a link to
a checklist for finding your own dataset as
well as resources for finding publicly available data.